so here we're showing dallas-fort Worth
area growing from 1984 to present day as
we loop back to 1984 you'll see a lot of
farmland up here where the suburbs that
spanned out now if we get to the next
the next frame we'll see the same view
now using lights at night and we're
seeing a compilation of 25 years of
lights at night and in red this ring
around here is a place where Dallas Fort
Worth got brighter so it's a place where
Dallas Fort Worth was growing now let's
zoom out to the whole US and what your
guests see here in the US are like these
red rings around each of the cities that
are growing so for example Atlanta
Dallas Fort Worth Houston Phoenix let's
compare that to China so let's go across
the planet and take a look at Shanghai
Shanghai in 1984 was relatively compact
about eight million people and by the
time we get to present-day you can't see
where Shanghai own so back to 1984 you
see all these separate cities and by
1984 I write present-day I should say
they've all combined now let's look at
that with lights at night you see a very
different story you see a little bit of
a green core but everything is red let's
zoom out do the rest of China now China
what we see is this rapid urbanization
and industrialization electrification
lots of population moving to the to the
coasts and you see not just these red
rings but you see entire areas along the
eastern seaboard turn red now you can
compare that yet compared to the United
States where again you see a lot of
places where it just stayed the same
especially up in the Northeast it's a
much less pronounced effect than what we
see in China today